let's talk about Star Fox zero oh boy
Peter Brown Star Fox zero you've been
playing it for what seems like an
eternity here in the office finally the
reviews up embargoes a seven out of town
in gainesville calm and i was expecting
a lower score maybe a little bit just
from some of the conversations were
happening around this game talking to
Rikard about it over giant bomb as well
he seems super dad honors as a big star
fox find your big star fox not as well
and is this very much like Star Fox 64
where does it fall short so it's like
Star Fox 64 in the sense that it uses a
lot of the same locations and characters
and events and even like remarks that
characters have like the catchphrases
you know you'll recognize them if you've
played starfox if somebody asked you to
do a barrel roll yeah do you then do the
thing that's not a barrel roll it's the
the himmelman yeah the whatever it's
called yeah I'm in maneuver yeah behind
and yoga verts it classic but you know
beyond all that sort of superficial
stuff the gameplay is fundamentally
different because it forces you to use
the gamepad in conjunction with the TV
because the game is the levels are
designed to like work in typical starfox
games where you fly is where your
reticle moves yes a one-to-one
connection in this game they're separate
you can hold down a button and keep them
connected but the moment you start
shooting the motion controls of gamepad
take over so you're essentially using
like an independent gun to fire within a
180-degree spectrum versus straight
ahead right so managing those two things
it's particularly looking between two
screens is very challenging and it's
proven to be a device of mechanic
especially for myself early on I felt
like this game is made this this series
is made worse by doing this coming out
of it I don't think it's made better by
implementing it but I got used to it and
I could and I could appreciate Star Fox
zero on its own terms for what it is
well that's kind of the thing with a lot
of new control schemes is that almost
immediately a lot of them unless they
feel very very intuitive like something
like I don't know maybe maybe tennis
maybe we tennis for instance yeah there
there are lots of controllers there you
go little like this you know to me like
it just doesn't feel right like if you
get like the first time I've you know
played a racing game with with wheels
instead of losing you know
control sticks on on a controller or not
we are sorry with pedals it just feels
like oh it feels weird again yeah um but
yeah you kind of get used to it after a
while or it becomes less yeah I mean I I
walked away from the gig the game
countless times the first few hours
because it was just it just I wasn't
enjoying myself and when I found myself
getting frustrated I felt like it was
because something was implemented
needlessly hmm you know and in the back
of my mind I'm thinking okay this is
them just to find the gamepad again like
I don't want to be a victim of their
their wins when against just feeling
better about their product but then
every time I came back like it started
to click more and more and it's sort of
one of those things like you know you
you have something in your subconscious
and you don't think about it but like in
the background like your brain is kind
of like figuring stuff out and the more
time I spend away from the game I came
back and I kept seeing this improvement
and so at that point it became less of
me wrestling with the controls and me
just playing the game just understanding
what it was there's even like an order
of operations you kind of have to assume
because when you're flying forward like
this game is mostly on Rails right right
aiming you can kind of do instinctually
because you sort of can understand where
the reticle is going to be but it's in
the all range mode where you're flying
in 3d space that it becomes particularly
difficult so I learned to look at the TV
position my ship where I wanted to be
with the enemies in sight then look at
the gamepad shoot them for as long as I
could start the process over again right
it's complicated a little bit less you
need yourself come off playing eve
valkyrie which is actually it's a really
good job of marrying those things
together right so yeah I mean starfox is
a very interesting game and the opinions
out there on it are equally interesting
I think yeah and seems like a good
who's-who of kind of old and new as well
the LA master tank is back in a sort of
a new form and into a jet yeah the or
wing can turn into a mech sometimes as
well it seems yeah and that's sort of a
they implemented something like that and
the unreleased version of Star Fox to
write like a bipedal mackin
affectionately known as the chicken
because it kind of looks and moves like
a chicken and then there's like also
like a gyro wing it's sort of like a
drone type copter hmm none of those are
really that fun and this might just me
personally but starfox for me it was
always about the joy of flight you know
even though you were shooting enemies in
the older games
that was all linked to flight in some
way yes everything you were doing was
bound to the art of flying and that
feeling you get when you're going
through tight spaces and stuff like that
and so yeah when stopping to pause to
like use the the gyrocopter to like drop
a robot that can go into a crevice it
just felt so tedious smells like get me
back to the action you know so there's a
lot of that here though which is great
so these new vehicles don't really take
away from stuff they don't really add a
whole lot either at least in my opinion
we talked a lot but than negative
negative aspects of a 70 town on
gamespot's pretty decent score though
all sinners so what is it about this
that sort of appeals to you like I'm a
wii u owner I'm not somebody who grew up
in Nintendo console so I don't I'm sorry
I know right Commodore baby is that
that's my Nintendo up there I'm a bit
jealous that he did that because you
could just copy your games I know right
yes and then they never made one again
read him but I guess you know I don't
have that nostalgia factor with us
necessarily starfox 64 was always one of
those games it seemed like that it was
it was a game that it had so much impact
not just because of how a play but also
just visually and everything what I was
doing was like holy [ __ ] like that video
game games can do this obviously that's
not necessarily the case in 2016 so what
is it about Star Fox zero that yeah gets
it a seventh time so part of what i was
talking about again is sort of the joy
of flight i think it captures the
essence of movement really well and
there are a lot of levels that sort of
service playgrounds for that sort of
action and those can either be really
fast or they can have the right mix of
enemies that make something challenging
in just the right way without being too
frustrating it was once you get used to
the controls so yeah it's just like it
really great set pieces as well like I'm
not gonna say the wii u does an amazing
job of making this game look incredible
but like you know when you're flying
around spaceships that are so big that
no matter how close you fly to it you
just feel like you're not getting any
closer yes I got big it's kind of you
feel that sense of scale so it's really
the fast-paced action mixed with flying
and some really great set pieces I kind
of found a nostalgia stuff that they put
in there to be a hindrance because I
really wanted this to be an opportunity
for a like a true modern sequel to Star
Fox and its really reimagining they
introduced some new levels and again
vehicles and even a character but for
the most part I felt like okay this
game I've played before it's just a
little more convoluted but that said
even though I'm done reviewing it unlike
a lot of games I review I can't want to
keep playing this just just for that fun
because it it delivers something that
the wii u doesn't have which is a great
space combat game so there you go there
you go also if you purchase you get
starfox guard softworks card starfox I'm
sorry virus scanner Miyamoto a 2000 e 3
2014 was interred showing off like two
concept games and one of the most
project guard it's a tower defense game
where you have to monitor 12 video
cameras okay um if I'm ready yeah kinda
yeah so you monitor these old video
cameras that have guns attached to them
and what you can do is you can switch to
the different cameras using the gamepad
and then you can shoot enemies that are
trying to invade your base okay and it's
kind of just that simple they introduce
new weapons introduce new enemies that
make things harder but it's really fun
and it's sort of set in this comical
part of the Star Fox universe where
you're working with slippy toads uncle
grippy god that's the naming convention
of that family they're going to run out
of ideas real soon yeah it's it's got
great character it's really it's really
accessible need to understand and it
ramped up in a really good way so you
have a lot of fun without getting
frustrated so that comes out that's
sorry that's just alongside of that's
bundled with Star Fox zero it's actually
its own separate physical package but
then you can also buy it on its own
digitally for 10 bucks sweet yeah
alright thank you so much boodram with
Star Fox are we finally after months of
talking about in the office we can talk
about it a review of course live up on
gamespot com 7 or 10 if you have any
thoughts please put them in the comments
below